la police n'est pas volé c'est bon ça
vous va c'est un peu juste
vous n'avez pas en xs sens pas pour moi
c'est pour un pote je test pour lui je
peux vous faire un ourlet j'arrive à
marcher j'ai trop mal aux pieds j'ai
deux seuls mecs sur le tapis rouge comme
ça
se faire recaler du tapis rouge donne
voilà où la bombe a finalement n'est pas
rentré parce que
le film était pas ou quoi on voulait
plus le voir cinquième homme pas saper
temps là je suis pas ça paie aujourd'hui
est un autre jour un autre jour je serai
bien habillé d'accord c'est bien parce
que toi je les aime pas ton visage
faisant face je fais ton étiquette qui
est totalement pas coupé quand on bat
les couilles mais que ce système
nick l'état avec qui le passent le coup
on bat les couilles de me voir je suis
là match attend au mois de juin
hu annuel sur la photo ah ouais t'as
déjà kullas de demers sa dette à laissac
à nous offrir des gains des gâteaux et
doux nom moi si vous voulez j'ai des
sacs à main à 5000 euros à 12 heures
moi je peux te sac à main ouais mais moi
je suis sac à main j'ai besoin on a
envie de me faire un cadeau
si j'accepte michaud nous de cannes
comme merci merci les mecs super les
contacts super concept l'investissement
qui s'est passé a dit adieu à gaspiller
j'ai pas envie de reprendre les deux
stars belges et gratter des aides à la
caf excusez moi ça me plaît et je suis
obligée tôt je suis français
est ce que tu as déjà eu quinze mecs en
costard
à donner mais comment tu vas pour tonner
comment est donc ses soixante dix ans
lundi le plus plat du monde savoir le
casual rails par la souffrance
notamment j'adore de redire mon rap
était mon violon donne aucun cerf-volant
pu violon les ravisseurs aillent au bout
du calife
en clair cuisery sur ton fils montceau
est toujours actif
mon sont en voie en soins palliatifs
voiliers ont effectué à west bay hill en
or le mague oui alors voir gros faux pas
de bisous deuxièmement je suis
prêt un doublement par
à la fin de l'audience à la bouteille
dame afrique a devancé les deux
sélections juste la même centrale à
l'alcool ouais je suis donc content
cerny montée
c'est un élément sérieux c'est quand tu
es tellement d'humour c'est d'abord et
contre toute attente norme allemande
finalement les marches de cannes mais
celle de la gare de cannes à la gare
sncf pour rentrer chez eux quand même
pas mal pour ses tubes heures de merde
voilà vous connaissez en indoor happen
adopte un mec c'est plus ou moins
toujours le même principe c'est pour
flirter rencontrer l'amour voir
pratiquer le sexe ou directement
pratiquer le sexe avant dans ma tête les
gens qui utilisaient ce genre
d'applications c'était plutôt des gens
comme ça n'ayant pas trouvé l'amour dans
les agences matrimoniales
je tente ma chance sur tintin ainsi
qu'aux heures à peine